alright we're going to see if I can make
ourselves a banner fall private match so
we're going to want to go in the game
options are going to want to change the
banner fall all right we're going to go
into banner fall guys because we need to
pick up that Ghost so that we can open
up that treasure box in the wing that
the srl is at and it's going to give you
a sparrow called lissandra scry but
first off we're going to head off in a
banner fall and a private match to get
this ghost and we're going to show you
we got to get that ghost alright so once
you get to the iconic tree here in
banner fall let's just face this way to
kind of make things easier you're going
to want to head this way towards this
side of the map and then we're going to
make our way over into this room here
and you're going to kind of see the
ghost already the tip of it it's right
there you can just kind of walk behind
it and here it is here's the ghost so
you're going to need this ghost to get
the do you need this goes to get access
to that box that treasure gift that we
have in the tower to get Lysander's cry
so now that we've gotten the ghost let's
head on back to the tower alright so
once you get back into the festive tower
we're going to head on over to the
sparrow racing league wing so to speak
as you can see i'm going to head on over
so we can open up that treasure box or
that gift box and get a shiny new
sparrow and to get that i'm going to
show you where to go i'm just going to
keep heading on over here and we're
going to head up the stairs
and whoops almost went too far I believe
if you just head to this back corner I'm
going to see a box right there and it's
a lie Sanders gift assuming i said that
right but yeah again you just need that
ghost that we got from banner fall and
we're going to go ahead and open up the
gift and now we have lice Sanders cry
which is a sparrow let's check out the
sparrow in question here there we go
let's preview it it's got a nice neon
green to it pretty cool uh yeah we can
give it a whirl out in the open world or
an srl but yeah that's how you get the
lice Anders Christ Sparrow for more
coverage of Destiny's rise of iron
donning a vent holiday event stay tuned
to gamespot com hit like hit subscribe
and we'll see you next time
[Music]